los ataques continúan en ucrania en la
zona norte en la ciudad de herning y su
alcalde está pidiendo ayuda porque
asegura que las tropas rusas están
rodeando toda la ciudad también en el
este en el donbass en donges y lugares y
en ciudades claves como archiv al
noreste y mariupol al sureste son
ciudades clave según ese nuevo plan del
kremlin en la segunda fase de la
ofensiva especial una ofensiva que pone
en duda ucrania y mucho más después de
los ataques esos misiles que impactaron
ayer aquí en libia dentro de esta guerra
de declaraciones y de cifras llama la
atención el número de generales rusos
muertos en esta invasión rusa son 7 y
muestra un poco la imagen de la magnitud
de pérdidas que está teniendo vladimir
putin en esta guerra por otra parte se
siguen evacuando a civiles de mariupol
completamente destrozada no hay un alto
al fuego así que esos civiles están
siendo evacuados bajo bajo el fuego
muchos de ellos están siendo evacuados a
ucrania pero también hay denuncias de
que se están produciendo
evacuaciones forzosas y traslados
forzosos a rusia